in this video we're going to go through
eight examples involving parabolas in
this particular form and we're going to
talk about how to graph them how to find
the vertex the focus the directrix as
well as how to complete the square and
put the quadratic equation into these
two forms here so let's dive into this
video and you're going to learn how to
work with these the first thing we want
to talk about is when you're working
with parabolas or quadratic equations of
these two forms you want to pay
attention to which variable is squared
so here you can see that Y is squared
which tells us that the parabola is
going to be opening to the right or to
the left if it's the X
term that is squared it's going to be
opening up or down now how can you tell
if it opens up or down well if the
p-value is positive it's going to open
up and if it's negative it's going to
open down same thing over here if p is
positive it opens to the right if it's
negative it'll open to the left and what
exactly is this P well the p is the
distance from the vertex to the focus
and that distance is also the same from
the vertex to the directrix so the
vertex is actually halfway in between
the focus and the directrix now what
exactly is a parabola let's talk about
that for a minute well it's the set of
all points that are equidistant from a
given point called the focus and a given
line called the directory so what that
means is like say if I had a point like
right here
and if I measure this distance to the
focus this distance to the directrix
that perpendicular distance they should
be the same now as you go further and
further out on the parabola the distance
to the directrix is going to get longer
so is the distance to the focus but
those two distances are always going to
be congruent or equal to each other so
that's what it technically is here this
Parabola is the set of all points that
satisfies those two requirements there
so let's go ahead and do an example and
I'll show you how this works so this
first example
we can identify the vertex by the number
group with the x is going to be the x
coordinate of the vertex
and the one group with the Y is going to
be the y coordinate but the signs are
going to be the opposite see how it's x
minus h and y minus K so that means that
our vertex is going to be at positive
one not negative 1 and negative 3 not
positive 3. so let's go ahead and graph
that 1 negative 3
. there's our vertex and notice this is
x squared that tells us the parabola is
going to open up like this or down like
this
in this case because you can see this is
negative it's going to be opening down
and notice this quantity right here this
negative eight that's our 4p so 4p is
equal to negative 8. if I divide by 4 P
equals negative 2 so what that tells me
is if I go down to that's my focus so
our Focus here is going to be at 1
negative 5 and if I go 2 up 1 2 that's
going to be
the directrix which is the line Y equals
negative 1.
and now what you can do is you can graph
this Parabola if you just want to do a
rough sketch but if you want to get a
couple of other key points what's
interesting is at the level of the focus
this chord here that goes through the
focus is going to be 4 P wide okay so in
this case you can see 4p is equal to 8.
so if I go half of that which would be 4
to the right 1 2 3 4 approximately here
and 4 to the left 1 2 3 4 approximately
here that gives me a width of 8 or 4p
and that kind of gives us a couple of
key points on our Parabola so that's a
pretty good sketch now let's look at
another example
let's go to number two now this one
notice it's a y squared type that tells
us that it's going to be opening to the
right like this or to the left notice
that this p-value is positive so that
tells us it's going to be opening to the
right okay our vertex is going to be the
number group with the x is going to be
the opposite sign that's going to be
positive 4 and the one group with the Y
that's going to be the opposite sign
negative 2 so it's going to be going one
two three four down two this is our
vertex let's just label that with a v
and you can see that 4p is equal to 4 so
that means that P is equal to 1. if I
divide both sides by 4 which means that
I'm going to go right one
there's my focus and left one that's my
directrix this directrix here you can
see is a vertical line so that's going
to be the line x equals 3 and our focus
is at the point
5 negative 2.
and now as far as graphing it we know
it's going to be opening to the right
and again we know that this focal chord
here this width at the level the focus
is going to be 4 P wide
let's just label that 4p 4p is equal to
4. so from the focus I'm going to cut
this four in half I'm going to go up to
put a point down to put a point and that
just gives me a couple of
points on my Parabola kind of gives me
an idea how wide or narrow it is and
we've got a pretty good sketch of our
graph okay for number three and four now
what we're going to do is we're going to
write the equation of the parabola given
some specific information and let's dive
into number three they're telling us
that the focus is at negative two I'm
sorry the vertex is at negative 2 5. so
left two up five I always like to draw a
sketch just to kind of help me visualize
and then the focus is at negative two
three so let's label that f for Focus so
what that's telling us is that remember
the parabola always opens away from the
directrix like towards the focus see
away from the directrix towards the
focus so what that tells me is that this
Parabola is going to look something like
this just a rough sketch this isn't
exact but it's basically opening down
which tells me that if it opens up or
down it's going to be in this x squared
format right and we can see that our
vertex is already given here so this is
like our H and our K so we can start off
by saying x minus negative 2 which is X
plus 2 squared equals 4p
and then y minus the y coordinate of the
vertex so y minus 5. now how do we
figure out what this p-value is right
here well remember the p is the distance
from the vertex to the focus so in this
case from the vertex the focus I can see
that that's two units here so that means
that this is going to be 2 times 4 which
is 8 but because this is opening down
it's going to be a negative 8 and that's
it you've got the equation in this
standard form here now for number four
a little bit different information
that's given they're giving us the focus
is at negative 2 positive 1. so let's
label that after Focus the directrix is
at x equals 2 so that's a vertical line
right here
and we know that the vertex is halfway
in between the directrix and the Focus
right so let's see halfway between this
is one two three four halfway would be
two so this is going to put us right
here
is our vertex so let's write that down
our vertex is at 0 1
and it's opening towards the focus away
from this directrix right so this is
going to be a y squared type because
it's opening left or right but because
it's opening to the left our p-value is
going to be negative now remember p is
the distance from the vertex to the
focus that's 2 in this case so we can
see that P is equal to two so let's go
ahead and write our equation so y minus
the y coordinate of the vertex equals 4
times 2 which is 8 but because it's
opening to the left this is going to be
negative 8.
x minus the x coordinate of the vertex
and we can simplify this a little bit x
minus 0 is just X so we could say this
is negative 8X and on this side is y
minus 1 the quantity squared
and that's our
equation
okay for number five and number six
we're still writing the equation but
we're given some different information
from previously here on number five
we're given the vertex is at the origin
zero zero
and it has a vertical axis and it passes
through the point negative 3 negative 12
which is somewhere down here
so so what this tells us when they say a
vertical axis this one has a vertical
axis so if you fold it over that axis of
symmetry it's going to match to itself
this one has a horizontal axis if you
fold it over it's going to match to
itself that way so this one because we
know it has a vertical axis it should
look like this where it's like this and
like this okay so that tells us since
it's opening down it's going to be in
this x squared form and our H and K are
going to be zero because the vertex is
at the origin so this equation basically
condenses down into x squared equals 4p
why okay we don't know what the p-value
is but let's see if we can solve for it
and we can do that because we know it's
going through this point negative 3
negative 12. so let's go ahead and put
negative 3 in for x
and negative 12 in for y and let's go
ahead and solve for this p-value so what
we can do is simplify here this comes
out to 9 equals negative 48p divide both
sides by negative 48 to get P by itself
and you can see now p is coming out to
negative 3 16. so if we reduce so we're
going to take this negative 3 16 put it
back in here
uh which comes out to negative 12 16
which is negative 3 4. so our final
equation x squared equals negative 3 4 y
would be our final answer for that one
for number six now
we've got a horizontal axis
a Vertex at 1 negative 3 which is right
about here horizontal axis looks
something like this and it passes
through the point 2 negative 1 which is
right here so that tells me that this
graph is going to look something like
this roughly okay if I fold it over that
horizontal axis it matches to itself and
that means it's going to be a y squared
type
so let's go ahead and write our equation
we have y minus the y coordinate of the
vertex so that's going to be y plus 3
squared
equals 4p
x minus the x coordinate of the vertex
we just need to solve for p how do we do
that well we know a point that the graph
is going through 2 negative one let's
plug that in for X and Y so we have
negative 1 plus 3
and 2 minus 1. so this comes out to 1
times 4 which is 4p
this comes out to 2 squared which is 4.
divide both sides by 4 you can see that
P equals 1 and what we're going to do is
we're going to put this one back in for
p here and we've got our equation so
this is just going to be y plus 3
squared equals 4 times 1 which is 4 x
minus 1 and you've got it in the
standard form
okay for number seven and eight these
last two problems we're going to do some
completing the square to write this
equation in the standard form then we're
going to find the vertex the focus the
directrix and we're going to graph it so
how do we do that well the first thing
we want to do is we want to analyze our
equation and ask ourselves is it the Y
squared term that's squared or is it the
X variable that's squared right in this
case it's a y y this is r squared not
the X's so that means it's going to be
in this form here
so what we're going to do is we're going
to get
the Y's on one side of the equation so y
squared minus 8y I'm going to add 8X to
both sides so this becomes a positive 8X
if I move it to the right and now what
we're going to do is we're going to
complete the square the way you do that
is you take this number in front of the
Y
divide it by 2 and square it so you'd
say negative 8 divided by 2 is negative
4 negative 4 squared is 16. now out of
thin air I'm adding 16 to the left side
of the equation to keep it balanced I
have to add 16 to the right side okay
now when we Factor this it's going to
factor to Y minus 4 the quantity squared
here I can factor out this leading
coefficient 8 so that's going to be X
plus 2. a quick tip here when you're
factoring this number here is always
going to be half of this B value so if
it was positive 8 this would be positive
4 if this was negative 8 it's negative
4. whatever this number is it's going to
be half and you can check your work by
squaring write this twice and foil it
out you'll get back the original but now
that we have it in the standard form
here it's easy to identify our vertex
which is going to be at negative 2
positive 4. remember those are the
opposite signs axis group of the X Y is
grouped with the Y so negative 2 4 would
put us right about here
okay and
our p-value see how this 8 is 4p so 4p
is equal to 8. divide both sides by 4 p
is equal to two we know that it's a y
squared type so it opens right or left
but because the p-value here is positive
that tells us it's going to be opening
to the right like this so if I go right
to
uh which is going to put me let's see at
right here so there's my focus so that's
focuses at
zero four
and then the directory so if I go 2 to
the left see this this p-value is 2 so
if I go 2 to the left that's going to
give me my directrix
which is at
x equals negative 4. so let's write that
down directrix x equals negative 4. and
then remember how we said that at the
level the focus it's 4 p y this focal
chord and in this case we said 4p is
equal to 8. if I cut the eight in half
go down four and up four okay at the
level of the at the level of the focus
here so down four and up four
and that's going to be about how wide
our Parabola is at the level of the
focus and that gives us a pretty good
sketch of our graph
let's take a look at another example
okay before we do this last example if
you like the way that I explain things
and you'd like to help support the
videos that I'm putting up here on my
Mario's math tutoring YouTube channel
consider becoming a channel member so
for a few dollars a month you can help
support the channel and I really
appreciate that you can also purchase a
t-shirt a math t-shirt for my Teespring
store you can look for the links down
below the video and in the description
so let's dive into this last example uh
x squared minus 4X plus 12y minus 8
equals zero notice this is an x squared
type that means we're going to try to
put it into this form here okay and
we're going to do that by completing the
square so get all the x's on the left
side of the equation let's go ahead and
move everything else to the right side
by subtracting 12y and adding 8.
remember when you switch from one side
to the other the signs are going to
change to the opposite and now to
complete the square we take this B value
okay and you can do this work off the
side you take the B value divided by two
and you square it so negative 4 divided
by 2 is negative 2 and negative 2
squared is 4. so I'm going to add out a
thin air 4 to the left side
four to the right side to keep the
equation balanced right now when we
Factor this trinomial it's a perfect
square
and remember that little trick I showed
you it's always going to be half of that
b value so x minus 2 the quantity
squared is equal to that trinomial we're
going to factor out the
negative 12 so that comes out to Y minus
1. and now we have this in the standard
form so we can identify our vertex which
is going to be 2 comma 1. remember it's
the opposite sign X is grouped with the
X Y is group of the Y so let's go ahead
and graph that 2 comma 1 is right here
vertex we know it's an x squared type
which means the graph is going to open
up or down because this is negative we
know it's going to open down like that
4p is equal to negative 12. so if I
divide by 4 P equals negative 3 which
means I'm going to go down 3 1 2 3
that's our Focus
which is at 2 negative 2
and our directrix if we go up 3 1 2 3
this is the line Y equals four so let's
write that down directrix y equals four
and then at the level of the focus we
know that it's going to be 4 p y
remember this focal chord P we said was
three four p is 12. if I cut 12 in half
and go 6 to the right one two three four
five six there's a point six to the left
one two three four five six there's a
point this kind of gives us a rough idea
about how wide
the parabola is at the level of the
focus of course it keeps getting wider
as you go further and further down but
that gives us a pretty good sketch of
our graph so
great job if you're able to follow this
and if you want to see more about
graphing conic sections meaning
parabolas like we did here as well as
ellipses hyperbolas circles I put a
comprehensive video that I did right
there follow me over to that video we'll
get some more practice and we'll learn
about how to graph other conic sections
in addition to parabolas I'll see you
over in that video